so we now have new polling that is
post-debate
but I mean post last week's debate there
was a debate last night we don't have
any polls completed after last night's
debate but last week remember Michael
Bloomberg had this absolutely disastrous
embarrassing performance at the
democratic debate the first debate in
which he participated and many people
believe Bloomberg support would
absolutely implode because of how bad
that debate performance was and it was
very very bad but it didn't happen we
now have to post debate polls and
Bloomberg support is unchanged
nationally from before the first debate
and he has actually grown support in
some key Super Tuesday States and I
believe Bloomberg will come away with a
respectable number of delegates on
Tuesday let's take a look
Bloomberg went into last week's debate
polling right about 15 percent
nationally and Bloomberg now with two
post debate polls is still polling about
15 percent nationally the numbers
highlighted in red on your screen are
Bloomberg's pre-debate polls you see
that he had 14 in each of the three most
recent pre-debate polls and then you see
the numbers in blue which are post
debate polls we're Bloomberg got a 13
and a 19 that is essentially no change
in Michael Bloomberg's polling from
before that absolutely terrible debate
performance and this is why I believe
Michael Bloomberg will buy Super Tuesday
see a slight uptick in support
nationally merely because last night he
did a little bit better than last week
if you were convinced by Bloomberg's
heavy ad campaign spending to support
him and then last night you see him come
in he doesn't blow the roof off the
place but he at least has some
preparation you probably are comfortable
voting for him if you were planning to
do it already next week now remember I'm
not a Bloomberg supporter I'm analyzing
this from the perspective of how he's
running his campaign Bloomberg had about
the worst debate performance you can
imagine last week and his support didn't
change and yesterday's debate
performance still made me cringe because
of what he was saying include
that he bought Congress but he was more
prepared he had comebacks they weren't
great but he had them and an okay
performance last night combined with
continuing to just pour money in is
probably going to grow his support by
Super Tuesday a little bit more I know a
lot of us just don't get it like how
could this possibly be but I am telling
you what I believe to be true not what I
want to be true and meanwhile let's look
at some of the Super Tuesday polls
Bloomberg is now polling in the
delegates in the in the viability
threshold for delegates in a number of
states in California there's a poll that
has Bloomberg at 21 can you imagine
as low as five but as high as 21 in
California in the latest poll in Texas
Bloomberg is polling 18 would get him
delegates in North Carolina Bloomberg
has surged to as high as 20 tied for
first place in one poll there the
Civitas poll then in Virginia only one
poll there from last week but Bloomberg
also tied for first place in Virginia
and then Florida which is a huge prize
worth 219 delegates Bloomberg is
straight up winning five points ahead in
Florida in the only poll from this month
what do you think is going on here
why is Bloomberg getting stronger
despite poor debate performances how
many delegates is Bloomberg going to
pull on Super Tuesday and understand the
importance to the math if you've been
looking at the delegate math and you
understand that to secure the nomination
at the convention you need 50% plus one
of the delegates Michael Bloomberg
pulling a bunch of delegates from
Florida Virginia maybe Texas California
possibly maybe North Carolina
if Bloomberg does that that makes the
path to 50% plus one far more difficult
for every other candidate Bloomberg has
no delegates right now every delegate
Bloomberg gets is a delegate that makes
it more likely nobody gets to 50% plus
one my question to you is why isn't the
guy Lou
support after these disastrous debate
performances let me know I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman we'll take a quick break and
be back right after this do you feel
like you just don't have enough time to
become as intellectually well-rounded as
you would like to be that there are just
not enough hours in your week for you to
read all of the books that you want to
read one of our sponsors is called
blinka stand it's an app that lets you
consume an entire nonfiction book in 15
minutes it's only about eight bucks a
month but you can try it for free for a
week and get 25% off a subscription when
you go to blankest comm slash Pakman
what blinka studs is take thousands of
popular nonfiction books and condense
them into either text or audio that you
can read or listen to in just 15 minutes
and what you get is all of the most
important ideas and information from the
book imagine being able to listen to an
entire nonfiction book in the amount of
time it takes you to drive or walk home
from work I just finished listening to
the way we eat now by bee Wilson whose
work I've recommended to you before
super interesting look at how the global
food system works and impacts the way
that we live blink is has totally
transformed how I consume information I
love it of course I read a book in its
entirety when I can but there are simply
just so many books that I want to read
and would not have the time for if it
weren't for blink Asst they have books
on politics economics philosophy science
you name it you can try it out yourself
totally free for a week and get 25% off
if you decide to subscribe just by going
to blink as comm slash Pakman I've put
the link right underneath this video
like the rest of us I bet you're going
into 2020 thinking about what you didn't
get around to in 2019 and your goals for
the new year if you want to work towards
being your best self in 2020 understand
more about the world around you and make
sure that your time is well spent then
blink astiz for you